[موسيقى]
تقدر تكسرها بوسها وقد قالها سابقا الاسد
الافريقي ابراهيم تراوري ارحلوا يا احفظ
لواس بكرامتكم والا سترحلون بدونها باريس
ترد في كبرياء لن نرحل ولسنا من يخدع
للتهديد بوركينا فاسو تقطع الحديث وتقول
للنيجر هيا لنذبح الديك الفرنسي ونقيم
مادوبه على شرف الدب الروسي قياده
الانقلاب في الني
الفرنسيه وتتركه لعده ايام بدون اكل او
شرب وعندما خاطبتهم فرنسا لماذا ردت عليهم
النيجر قائله دعوه يتذوق قليلا من جوع
افريقيا الوضع يخرج عن السيطره والقوات
الروسيه تنتشر في النيجر تهديدات التدخل
العسكري تتبخر في الهواء لتعلن دلوعه
اوروبا عن هزيمتها نعم ها هو مكروه يرفع
رايته البيضاء معلنا عن هزيمته في النيجر
قائلا اعترف بهزيمتي فقط اتركوني ارحل في
سلام فرنسا تسحب جنودها وقواعدها من
النيجر وفي تلك الزاويه بوتين يضحك معلنا
عن انتصار دون خساره ايه طلقه رصاص لا
تستغرب فتلك هي فلسفه الحرب التي يجيد
بوتين اللعب على اوتارها كيف طردت النيجر
الفرنسيين من اراضيها ولماذا
صاحب قوته من النيجر وما هو التحالف
الافريقي الذي صنعه بوتين ليدق بهم مسمارا
اضافيا في نع
شقيه القادمه التي سيلتهمها بوتان لتعرف
اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه
الانذار الاخير
يبدو ان السادس والعشرين من يوليو سيكون
التاريخ الذي ستكتب به شهاده وفاه
العنجهيه الفرنسيه فبعد انقلاب النيجر اهم
معاقل احفاد الاوس في افريقيا وازاحه
حليفهم الوثيق محمد بازوم عن الحكم الديك
الفرنسي يهدد بالعقاب الشديد اذا لم يتم
اعاده حليفه وخادمه الوفي الى الحكم راهن
مكروه على دعم امريكا ولكن سرعان ما خذله
العم وسام قائلا له لا طاقه لي بمواجهه
الدب الروسي فراهن على مجموعه ايكواس
ولكنهم خذلوه ايضا ياتي شهر اغسطس قاده
النيجر يواجهنا انذارا للسفير الفرنسي
سيلفان ايتي امامك مهله 48 ساعه ارح الا
ستندم تمر المهله وسيلفان ايتيل لا يزال
متشبثا على امل اخذ رشفه من بحر
اليورانيوم متوقعا عوده فرنسا الى قياده
النيجر القوات النيجيريه تتدخل وترفع
الحصانه الدبلوماسيه عن السفير الفرنسي
وتحتجسه مع مجموعه من موظف السفاره
الفرنسيه ليس هذا فحسم بل ان الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرونوس الراحه ان
العسكريين فنيجر يحتجزون السفير الفرنسي
وموظفين دبلوماسيين لافتا الى ان الطعام
الذي يتناولونه عباره عن حصص غذائيه
عسكريه ولا يتم
الا وجبتين او وجبه في اليوم فلماذا هذا
الحزن يا هذا فلتتذوق قليلا من الجوع الذي
تذوقته افريقيا في فتره احتلالكم وليس هذا
فقط بل ان النيجر فتحت مجالها الجويه مره
اخرى امام جميع الرحلات ولكنها اغلقت
الباب في وجه فرنسا بكل عنف ففي بيان لها
قالت المجال الجوي للبلاد مفتوح امام جميع
الرحلات التجاريه الوطنيه الدوليه
باستثناء الطائرات الفرنسيه او الطائرات
التي تستاجرها فرنسا وبينها تلك العائده
الى اسطول اير فرانس ماكرون جنه جنونه
ولكن دون فائده
اعلان الهزيمه
حاول مقروء استعطاف المجتمع الدولي وصرح
قائلا في النيجر لدينا صفير وموظفون
دبلوماسيون محتجزون كراهاء في السفاره
الفرنسيه
تم منع توصيل المواد الغذائيه لهم وهم
ياكلون حصصا عسكريه محدده ويتم منعهم من
بعض الوجبات لياتي الرد سريعا من القاره
السمراء حذرناك من قبل يا ماكرون ولكنك
وقعت ضحيه عن جاهيتك الفارغه والان عليك
ان تتحمل نتيجه عنادك ظل قده النيجر في
انتظار ما سيفعله الديك الفرنسي ولكن كما
يقول المثل تمخض الجبل فولد فارا هنا
دلوعه اوروبا ونقصد باريس تعلن هزيمتها
اخيرا وترفع رايتها البيضاء في النيجر
ليقرر ماكرونوسا بس سفير الفرنسي سيلفان
ايتي بل وسحب جميع القوات الفرنسيه من
النيجر والبالغ عددها 1500
وقال ماكرون في بيان رسمي قررت فرنسا
اعاده سفيرها خلال الساعات المقبله وانهاء
التعاون العسكري مع النيجر اما الجنود
الفرنسيون فسوف يغادرون النيجر خلال
الاسابيع او الاشهر المقبله وسيتم
الانسحاب الكامل من هناك بحلول نهايه
العام الجاري ماذا
ستفعله ايها الديك العملاق يبدو ان صوت
صياحك اعلى بكثير من قوتك الحقيقيه مئات
او قولي الالاف من النيجيريين لم ينتظر
حتى الصباح بل ذهبوا للاحتفال بانتصارهم
امام القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه
وكانهم يحتفلون بالتحرر من احتلال ومصر
دماء وثروات دام لعشرات السنين
المصائب لا تاتي فرادى وكان العملاق
الافريقي الصاعد ونقصد هنا بوركينا فاسو
لا تصمت فلكل فعل رده فعل فبحسب وكاله
رويترز امر الجيش البركيني الملحق العسكري
الفرنسي
بمغادره البلاد خلال اسبوعين على الاكثر
والا سيواجه نفس مصير نظيره في النيجر وما
فعلته النيجر بالسفير الفرنسي ليس ببعيد
فكر جيدا يا باسكي فالافارقه لا يمزحون
واسال زميلك ووسط كل هذا يقف بوتين يضحك
من بعيد ويقول لماكرون مهلا المصائب لم
تنتهي بعد هناك كارثه اخرى في انتظارك يا
عزيزي فما هي الكارثه الروسيه التي تنتظر
باريس في القاره السمراء
التحالف الاسطوري لهدم المعبد الغربي
من سياسه الحروب الذكيه هو ان تخضع عدوك
وتجبره على الاستسلام دون ان تطلق طلقه
واحده هكذا قالها بوتين عند استضافته
لاحدى قمم دول افريقيا وفي صفعه جديده على
وجه احفاد لواس قررت دب الروسي انشاء
تحالف عسكريا خاص به وجعل مخالبه في
افريقيا اكثر حده في بيان المشترك اعلنت
كل من النيجر ومالي وبوركينا فاسو
والجزائر وهم ايادي بوتين في الساحل
الافريقي انشاء حلف دفاع مشترك بينهم تحت
مسمى تحالف دول الساحل وان اي اعتداء على
اي دوله منهم سيعتبر اعتداء على الدول
الاربع ففي مالي استوت الطبخه الروسيه
واصبحت خاليه تماما من الوجود الفرنسي
العسكري وفي بوركينا فاسو ها هي الطبخه
على وشك الانتهاء تعهد البلدان بالدعم
الكامل لصديقتهم التي توشكه هي ايضا على
طرد احفاد لويس رسمي ونقصد هنا النيجر وكل
ذلك برعايه واشراف من بوتين فمالي
وبوركينا فاسو كانت اول دولتين تقفان
بجانب النيجر بعد الانقلاب وعندما اعلنت
فرنسانيتها التدخل العسكري كان البلدان
اول من يعلن تحالفهم العسكري مع النيجر
وان اي تدخل او اعتداء على النيجر سيعتبر
اعتداء على الدول الثلاث وعلى راسها
الجزائر والتي رفضت اي تدخل عسكري ضد
النيجر وان كنت تقلل من دور مالي وبوركينا
فاسو والجزائر فيكفي ان اقول لك يا عزيزي
ان هذه الدول كانت الشوكه التي عطلت اهم
تحالف عسكري ضد النيجر ونقصد هنا تحالف
الايكوس الموالي اغلبه لباريس والغرب
فوجود مالي وبوركينا فاسو ضمن مجموعه
ايكواس ورفضهم التدخل العسكري هدف في
النهايه الى تشتيت التحالف وافشال امل
فرنسا الاخير في استعاده اهم معاقلها بال
وبالطبع كل هذا تحت اشراف روسيا الامر ليس
مجرد تحالف من اربع دول يا عزيزي فباريس
تعد فرائصها من ان يتوسع هذا التحالف ويضم
دولا افريقيه اخرى وتقع افريقيا كلها
بكنوزها ومواردها رويدا رويدا في قبضه
الدب الروسي والذي لم يرحم حتى اقوى دوله
في العالم قبل ان يسيطر على كل تلك الكنوز
فما بالك عندما تقع جميعها في قبضته فماذا
تظنه سيفعل السؤال لكم الان مشاهدينا هل
الاعتراف فرنسا بهزيمتها سيكون اخر
معاركها في افريقيا ام ان هناك جولات اخرى
تنتظر الديك الفرنسيه والدب الروسيه في
القاره السمراء ومن الذي سينتصر في
النهايه اخبرونا في صندوق التعليقات
[موسيقى]